[Music]
picture Palace has been one of his
proudest achievements and now it's
feeling the consequences of the Jeffrey
Epstein scandal accountancy firm KPMG
one of the founding partners has decided
not to renew its sponsorship of the
event for entrepreneurs because of the
adverse press scrutiny around Prince
Andrew the pharmaceutical company Astra
Zeneca also told us they're currently
reviewing but to continue their
partnership which expires this year The
Dukes controversial interview was meant
to end the focus on his links with
Epstein and let him get on with his work
but the outward-bound Trust of which his
patron says they're holding a board
meeting in the next few days which will
inevitably consider his position every
charity if if they're working with
famous faces or royal patrons should
really have a crisis communications plan
in place so that if anything does go
wrong that they know how to react
whether it's something they should
actually comment on or whether it's
something that they should stay out of
the conversation about because often it
may not actually have a direct impact on
the charity itself within the palace
it's also caused divides with
suggestions his team were operating as a
silo not involving the likes of the
Queen in their plans for an interview
until very late in the day we know that
the Duke of York said that he needed to
seek approval from higher-up and the
Queen was aware of the interview before
it took place but it has been made clear
to me today that ultimately it was the
princes decision to do that interview at
the moment they are coming across as a
household divided at a time when they
should be pulling together to deal with
the fallout when asked do you believe
the explanation that Prince Andrew gave
or not just 6% of respondents said yes
while more than half 51 percent said no
and 43% said they don't know we also
asked do you think the way that Prince
Andrew has responded to the allegations
has damaged the monarchy 47 percent said
yes
23 percent no and 30 percent said they
no it was inevitable the interview would
overshadow other important Boyle work
with Prince Charles and Camilla on tour
in New Zealand and Prince William and
Kate out in London his team had hoped
that speaking out would be a chance for
him to get the attention back on his own
projects instead the controversy has
focused mines on what his future role
should be within one of our most
important institutions Rhiannon Mills
Sky News